There's a famous saying that women have to do twice as much work as men to
receive half of the credit. That's likely,
never been true that in the life of Maria Teresa,
the eldest daughter of Holy Roman emperor, Charles, the sixth, Maria Teresa,
was born at a time when the idea of a woman running Austria was as absurd
as giving the poor, the votes.
When she took over from her father aged just 23,
she was immediately forced to fight for her empire.
His very survival as Europe's Kings sought to tear her inheritance away from her
yet fight Maria Theresa did not only that she won.
When the dust finally settled,
it was on a strengthened Austria that would soon transform the entire continent
over the next three decades of her rule.
Maria Theresa enacted reforms that changed the world,
fought off attacks from powerful enemies and gave birth to a litany of
famous children, including Marianne's. When ads through cunning,
tactical marriages and sheer obstinate obstinacy she forced a once hostile
Europe to bend to our will. Today.
We're investigating the story of one of Europe's most influential.
She was born in Vienna on may the 13th, 1770 units,
likely Maria Teresa sets a world record in disappointing our parents.
That was because she was born a she at a time when Austria desperately needed
a Royal baby boy, Maria Theresa, his father was Charles the sixth,
Holy Roman emperor, and a member of the powerful Hapsburg dynasty.
Unfortunately,
the Habsburgs golden rule was that only males could inherit their crown lands,
swath of territory, including modern Austria, Hungary, and the Czech Republic.
Plus trunks of everything from modern day Romania to Croatia to Belgium.
This was fine when emperors were syring baby boys and had a plethora of brothers
waiting in the wings. But Charles had neither,
as far as the continent was concerned, unless Charles had a son,
the house of Habsburg would soon go extinct along with him.
But Charles thought he had found a new pole in 17, 13,
five years before Maria Theresa failed to be born with a Y chromosome.
The emperor issued something known as the pragmatic sanction,
essentially a piece of legislation that said, you know what?
We're cool with girls. Now, the sanction trying to put into law,
the idea of female inheritance at first, it was purely hypothetical,
but after Maria Therese was born,
Charles began a PR drive to make everyone accepted.
Since the hops Habsburg glands weren't unified.
That means spending years traveling to various Austrian Dutchies and kingdoms
like Bohemia and trying to convince stuffy 18th century dudes,
that girls were more than just vectors for spreading cuties. Unfortunately,
deep down, it seems that even Charles himself didn't believe this.
Although the sanction mentoring might soon be Empress,
Maria Teresa's childhood was spends learning zero necessary skills.
But to give you just one example,
it was customary for male as to learn the empire fiendishly complex languages
like Hungarian and check the Maria Theresa was instead given courses in
languages designed to make her more malleable like French, Latin,
nor was she taught anything about diplomacy, warfare politics,
or even the basic practicalities of running an empire.
It's almost like Charles was just fundamentally incapable of imagining a female
ruler, no matter what his sanction might say,
even trying to marry his daughter off to a powerful print suit,
at least be able to defend the Empire's integrity.
But that plan fell by the wayside.
When his now teenage daughter went and fell for friends,
Stephan the air to the territory of Lorraine friend,
Stephan was certainly important,
but he was also way more a dreamer than he was a mighty warrior.
Still to his credit.
Charles allowed his daughter to marry for love rather than dynastic reasons.
They laughably rare occurrence at the time.
There is still that love actually survived just by your friends,
being the sort of guy who couldn't go five minutes without removing his pants
and making for the nearest countless Maria Teresa doted on him over the next
decades, the union would produce 16 children, including two Hodi,
Roman emperors and Marie Antoinette.
Those children would be prodigious baby makers too.
By the time she eventually died, Maria Teresa would be a grandmother,
56 times over sadly,
none of our first children would have that elusive Y chromosome on the 20th of
October 17, 40 Charles, the sixth diet age, just 23,
Maria Theresa ascended to the Austrian throne. At first,
it looks like the pragmatic sanction had worked.
She made her husband CCO regions and the various Dutchies and kingdoms of the
Hamburg lands recognized hut.
But while the sanction may have smoothed the transition internally,
it certainly hadn't worked where the rest of Europe was concerned to the
continents. Male rulers,
Maria Theresa was an illegitimate Empress sitting a top,
a whole lot of prime real estate.
There was only one way that this could have a pan out. It was time for Europe.
In retrospect.
One of the most impressive things about Charles the sixth is just how incapable
he was a planning.
We've already seen how he didn't prepare Maria Theresa for ruling Austria,
but he also failed to prepare Austria for Europe, ignoring his sanction.
There was no military buildup prior to his death,
no money or weapons set aside for defending the crown lands.
As his daughter later commented, she became head of an Ambar with no money,
no army, no experience and no advisers given all that.
Perhaps the only surprising thing is that the war took two whole months to kick
off the ball. Started rolling with the moment Maria,
Theresa ascended to the throne. See the emperor before Charles Joseph,
the first had likewise failed to produce any male. As when he died in 1711,
the throne had passed to his younger brother, our friend, Charles,
but Joseph had had daughters. Some of whom had married, powerful men. Now,
Charles, his daughter had become ruler, those powerful men,
but wondering why their wives, Joseph,
the first starters didn't get to inherit Austria.
The biggest challenges came from the electors of Saxony and Bavaria who had
formed an Alliance with Austria's old rival France,
and started making claims on her territory.
But the major threats Maria Teresa's rain would come from another direction
entirely over in Prussia. Frederick,
the great was newly on the throne and determines to live up to his future
nickname on December the 16th,
1740 his army marched into the filthy rich Habsburg province of Silesian Danek
States. It was the starting gun on the war of Austrian succession.
It would very nearly result in the destruction of Maria Teresa's embalm the
early days of the war with marks by Maria Theresa scrambling to even get a
shred of legitimacy as pressure wipes, the floor with Austria's troops,
the young women floundered for allies. Her biggest win came in June of 1741.
When she visited the Hungarian diet, a newborn baby son,
clutched in her arms and gave a rousing address asking for the nobleman support
shortly after she was officially crowns queen of hungry.
But this was just a small Island amid a sea of catastrophe that
July Charles Albert of Bavaria invaded Bohemia and had himself crowned King in
Prague. At the same time,
French troops marched into Austria bringing the FYS onto Habsburg tough as their
inheritance evaporates it before arise.
Maria Teresa tried to hold onto the title of Holy Roman emperor.
Although not hereditary. The title had been in our family for centuries,
although there was no chance of a female. Holy Roman emperor,
Maria Theresa hoped to at least convince the electors to appoint her
husbands. Instead,
she was forced to watching horrors Charles Albert managed to get the empire
electors onto his side on February the 12th, 1742.
He was crowned Holy Roman and burrow Charles the seventh,
the first non Habsburg to hold the tire. So linen almost 300 years.
It was a crushing peolpe lawyer for the young inexperienced Maria,
Theresa the Europe at large,
it looks like final proof that the game was over for this upstart female
pretender.
You know how they say that the night is always darkest before the Dawn,
while the sun was about to come up on Maria Teresa's fortunes. And when it did,
she was going to show all those over-confident men. What she was really made of
Three's Maria Teresa one, or one's on the battlefields,
but in the realm of diplomacy in 1741 before Charles Albert became Holy Roman
emperor, she persuaded the British to join her side, to be fair.
This wasn't that difficult. Even today.
British logic operates on they're kind of the enemy of France is my friend track
and Australia was very much Franz's enemy,
but it was still a significant win of all the powers attacking Maria Teresa's
EMBA fronts was the scariest with Paris suddenly tied up fighting in London.
It gave Austria's army a chance to act in the spring of 1742.
While Charles Albert was still sat in Frankfurt, acting all smug,
Austria invaded and occupied his home state of Bavaria.
Then before the Emberin you wanted hit and Maria Teresa swallowed her pride and
did something very painful.
She gave Frederick the great exactly what he wanted in return for giving up
Silesian Maria Teresa ensured her other scary enemy pressure was
awesome out of the war.
And now left only weaklings like Bavaria to deal with by may of 1743 Austria's
troops had retaken Bohemia leaving Charles Albert and Xcel without a kingdom
that same month, Maria Teresa was officially crowned queen of Bohemia in Prague,
a slightly gross experiences.
The corpses of enemy troops were still blowing in the streets.
Not long after the British smashed the fringe,
the basle of dashing and not September Maria Theresa convinced salvo to join the
war faced with mounting losses and new enemies to fight the French were all
like, you know what? Forget this and retreated back to that borders,
leaving poor Charles out at all isolated,
although the war would drag on for several more years,
it was already effectively Aviva in January, 1745,
Charles Albert died whilst in on XL, seeing how hopeless the situation was,
his son and success at cut a deal in return for Austria.
Withdrawing from Bavaria had to give up all claims on the reiterates,
his territory, that autumn, the Holy Roman Ambar elected friends,
Stephan as its new ruler under the name Francis the first,
although it was a husband's on the throne,
Maria Theresa never left any doubt about who was really calling the shots as the
war wound down. The only bum note was the permanent loss of sight,
leisure to Frederick the great Australia game lead,
trying to find and reclaim it.
But given he's known as Frederick the grace and Frederick the crappy,
you can probably guess how that wins.
The war of Austrian succession finally ended in October of 1748 against all the
odds Maria Theresa had done it whilst I Nisha was gone.
The rest of the territory was intact.
The title of Holy Roman emperor was back in our family and Europe was no longer
in any doubt about a woman ruling Austria.
If she'd been just a little less skilled at diplomacy,
a little less quick on her feet,
Maria Teresa could have watched her entire legacy vanished before arise.
Instead,
her EMBA would now survive in one form or another all the way into world war
one, but Europe's young emperor.
Wasn't mentally content with holding her territory.
The word exposed how weak her empire really was,
how decentralized and vulnerable. If Maria Theresa wanted her lands to survive,
she was going to have to give them a serious overhaul this well,
could she have known just how far reaching the impact of these reforms would be
Contradiction of Maria Teresa's life is that her reforms will liberalize the
whole of Europe all while she herself was a staunchly Catholic conservative on
paper.
Maria Theresa had no inclination towards improving our subjects lives than
Napoleon had. So not conquering everything in sight,
but she was a practical person. If reform would benefit our empire,
she would pursue it regardless.
It was this quality that would turn her into one of the greatest rulers in
history.
The transformation that took place some to Maria Theresa can be summed up with
three words, centralization, professionalization, and deficiency.
Let's talk with them in order.
The first thing to know is that the Habsburg lands were not a unified empire.
Each of the regions had its own feudal dot ruling at the local level.
This means that the empire had no control over local administration,
relying on a handful of Lords and bishops to do everything from collect taxes,
to write laws, Maria, Teresa swept all this archaic nonsense away under her.
Watch the empire,
his various parts were integrated into a coherent whole new civil servants were
trained to take over from the dots,
the nobility and the church lost both their powers and their tax exempt status
with this political centralization game,
the drive to do the same for the economy.
Internal tariffs that had existed for centuries were abolished the entire empire
absorbed into a single market.
The census was introduced and researchers sent to gather data on the Empire's
lands, allowing for more rational policies to be formulated,
to do all this census taking and administering Maria Theresa stopped her long on
unqualified members of the nobility and started promoting the professional.
Middle-class likewise,
the buffoonish aristocrats in the military were ejected and actual competent
officers were brought in for the first time.
Australia was able to maintain a standing army trained in the latest warfare
techniques. And just as centralization naturally led to professionalization.
So creating this new professional class inevitably led to overhauling education.
One of the biggest triggers came in 1749.
When the judiciary was separated from the state,
this created a sudden desperate need for learning judges alongside all of the
new civil servants. So Maria Theresa threw open the doors to higher education.
She approved there's then radical notion that students should be taught from
textbooks. She also took education out of the hands of the church.
Ensuring subjects were taught by people who knew what they were talking about,
but the biggest change was the slow introduction of compulsory schooling.
The first step towards universal primary education, of course,
for Maria to raise the point of all of this wasn't to educate the populace,
but to quickly train the educated class,
her other reforms called for that's what we meant by efficiency,
but higher efficiency still came with a giants.
If accidental dose of enlightenment ideals take a economic
reform of physio, cracy at its most basic physio.
Cracy suggested that a higher birth rate would produce more workers,
which would make the empire richer realizing that ill-treated peasants.
Weren't able to sustain packs of children.
Maria Theresa eliminated the rights of feudal overlords to dominate their
peasants lives. She also overhauled healthcare,
seeing the death rates about women during childbirth,
Maria Theresa founded the first maternity hospitals and did obstetrics
departments while also forcing midwives and qualifications instead of just
improvising. Oh,
and she also champions inoculation against smallpox putting a ahead of
anti-vaxxers before there were even any vaccines to be anti about in
short Maria Theresa completely overhauled her empire,
dragging it into the modern world. So successful.
When many of her reforms that they'd be taken up by other European leaders,
adding to the era of enlightened absolutism. Now sweeping the continent.
But while she's famous today as a reformer,
that doesn't mean every reform Maria Theresa undertook was a good one.
It's time. We took a hard look at the darker side of her,
The hardcore Catholic Maria Theresa naturally disliked anything that smacked of
heresy. Unfortunately, that included a good number of her own subjects.
The first target of our prejudices were Protestants,
even though the Counter-Reformation had been dead and buried for a century,
Maria, Theresa still felt Protestantism was fundamentally in legitimate.
When it came time to resettle, depopulated lands in what is today, Romania.
It wasn't Catholics that she shipped out that econ a living,
but Protestants who'd been expelled from the cities,
but at least this was still in keeping with a practical side.
She had a region that needed saddling.
So she sends her unwanted Protestants that the same,
couldn't be sad of a persecution of the Jews,
despite the Jewish community in Prague, dating back centuries,
Maria Theresa kicks off a rain by expelling. At 20,000 of them,
Jewish families were given almost no warning before their community.
It was dissolved ending generations of tradition. And so I think I was thinking,
Oh, that's just how things worked in the 18th century mysteries, his own son,
Joseph,
the second would pass a law right after she died and doing most of anti-Jewish
legislation. The other minority,
Maria Theresa had no truck where there was anyone who didn't believe in
God-fearing Catholic marriage, unsurprisingly, this included gay people.
It also included anyone who committed adultery and even Catholics who dead to
have sex with Protestants to enforce this.
She introduced a chastity course that could order anything from whipping to
deportation to execution that's if they survive the torture.
Yup. Torture. Well,
a general move to outlaw torture was gathering steam across Europe,
Maria Theresa resisted it,
believing the practice was still necessary and useful. Finally,
there was a toxic relationship with her son in 1765. Friends,
Steven died leaving Maria Theresa heartbroken the very next day she elevated her
eldest son, Joseph.
The second two are co regions successfully getting him likewise installed as
Holy Roman emperor. But as long as she was alive, that was no doubt.
She was really in charge.
This was unfortunate because Joseph had inherited his mother's reforming zeal
boosted even further by his enlightenment beliefs.
This meant toleration for other religions,
extended rights for the very poorest and open admiration for a mega reformer
Frederick. The great soundly, all anathema to Maria Theresa is the,
we had results was the Marie-Therese.
I spent the first half of her reign transforming our empire and the second half
fighting tooth and nail to stop her son from taking those reforms to their
logical conclusions. But we shouldn't write her off.
As I may have precast to Josephs. Although overhauls were baby steps,
they were genuinely groundbreaking for the time taking place years before other
reformers like Catherine,
the great arrived on the scene and certainly decades before Napoleon.
If it hadn't been for having to share consonant with the great it's likely Maria
Teresa would likely have been by far the most significant Monica at a time,
but there were other ways that she was significant for Europe too. It's time.
We took a look at Maria Teresa's other great skill, marriage, diplomacy.
Practicality.
It was water driven.
Maria Theresa's reforms it's certainly was what governs our attitude to family,
her kids. Weren't living children,
but commodities to invest in or else Mary off to powerful rulers.
And no one did marriage diplomacy quite like Maria,
Theresa starting in the 1750s.
She decided to neutralize the French threats by marrying as many of our
daughters to as many bobbin princes as humanly possible famously.
This included Marie Antoinette, it's known in Austria as Maria Antonia,
who was sent to France to Mary Lou the 16th,
but it also included nearly all her other girls,
nearly all called Maria Maria Karoleena. For example,
was dumped into King Ferdinand of Naples and Sicily rule-out once described as
both uncouth and mentally retarded Maria AMA Lee begged not to be forced to
marry the Duke of Palmer only to find herself on happily walking down the aisle
with him. Even when marriage was concerned,
there was a ruthlessness to Maria Teresa. When Maria Elizabeth,
his good looks were ruined by smallpox.
She was entirely removed from the mother's marriage schemes and left an
isolation to go half matte. In fact,
the only daughter Maria Theresa extended the same courtesy a father had to her
was Maria, Christina.
She was allowed to marry for love and to do pretty much as she pleased the rest
of this gigantic brood of Maria has spent their entire lives controlled and
dominated by that powerful mother. This was a key part of marriage diplomacy.
The daughters installed in helpful locations.
Maria Teresa would write to them telling them exactly what to do and how to
behave.
It drove Maria internet bonkers causing her to confide in her XY friends,
that her mother was a dreadful old cow. She may have had a point.
Maria Theresa seems to have regarded all of our daughters as inherently stupid
and in need of berating. Like the times she had bluntly told one of them,
the less you speak the better I know the manner in which you chatter away and
must tell you as a friends,
that it is very tedious and lauded with all sorts of platitudes, ouch,
but the children were more than just Canon invite for marriages.
They were PR tools to Maria.
Theresa knew from experience that being a female ruler was often a handicap,
but she knew it could also work to her advantage.
When invariable male diplomats arrived from foreign lands, she'd greet them.
The company it's about all her children, projecting womanly virtues,
like motherliness and caring that convinced these stuffy dudes.
She wasn't a threat. It was cold. It was calculating.
It was unfair to our kids. And it also works.
Thanks to this practical attitude towards her offspring,
Maria Teresa was able to turn the French into our allies to make enemy States
into grudging friends. Well,
at least until the French Rose up and chopped off her daughter's hat,
but that is a tale for another video. All in all.
Then Maria Theresa's family diplomacy was at quad and in Europe,
at least for a time, sadly time was something Maria Teresa, no,
The slow March toward the end of Maria Teresa's life began on August the 18th,
1765. That day friends Steven died suddenly ripping away.
The one person she truly adored. Although some Joseph,
the second would be elevated to co regions.
The effect Fran Stephen's death had on her would be catastrophic for the rest of
her life. Maria Theresa workloads that morning,
she stopped attending public events,
close herself away and slipped into something that looks suspiciously like
depression.
The most pathetic remnants of this time is probably a piece of paper found after
she died. And it should work out exactly how long the marriage had lost it.
29 years, six months, six days, that makes 29 years,
335 months, 1,540 weeks,
10,781 days,
258,744 hours.
It was around this time that she also became increasingly conservative.
We've already mentioned how Maria Teresa changed from a reformer into someone
fighting her son's edicts at every turn. Well,
this about face also applied to foreign policy ever since the war of Austrian
succession, Maria Theresa had promoted herself as the impressive piece.
Someone who wanted to stop war coming to Europe, but in 1772,
she took pallets along with pressure and Russia in the first partition of
Poland, annexing, Galicia, and threatening the entire balance of Europe.
As I roll down to me, Frederick, the great stared at a reluctant annexation.
She wept, but she took nonetheless as the years, began to mountains up.
Maria Theresa started to fail physically from alive athletic women.
She became badly overweight, a son, a future, Holy Roman, emperor Leopold.
The second wrote despairingly owing her agents at corpulence.
She is beginning to have great difficulty in walking.
Her memory has deteriorated considerably.
She mistrusts herself and everybody else.
She never enjoys anything and is constantly alone and melancholic at lost.
Her alien body gave out completely Maria Theresa died of pneumonia on November
the 29th, 1780 age 63,
she was buried in Vienna alongside her beloved friend, Steven,
the PA finally reunited after a decade and a half apart at the moment of her
passing,
it wasn't clear how Maria Teresa would be remembered or reforms that had once
seemed so revolutionary now looked like mere tinkering compared to those of
Joseph. The second, not a decade later,
even Joseph's reform is pale in comparison with the changes,
the French revolution unleashed against all that came after.
What were the basic practical changes that Maria Theresa had made.
But this wasn't the story's ends.
As the years marched on it soon became clear that Maria Theresa had laid the
foundations for Austria's golden age. As the empire lived longer and longer,
all the way into the 20th century.
It started to look more and more like Maria Teresa's practical spirit had been
perfect for a time and place today. Of course,
with Austria's emperor over a century,
dead are far more likely to remember other aspects of Maria Theresa's.
He was a powerful woman who didn't just manage to rule at a time when ovaries
could have disqualified her from the top spot,
but did so with a force and passion that made her one of the most influential
monarchs in Europe as a height.
She bends both Austria and Europe to her well and did so in a way that benefited
millions. She may have been religiously intolerance.
She may have lived long enough to become an obstacle to reform rather than its
driver.
But Maria Teresa was a ruler who saw off all of her rivals to rain for 40 long
years in doing so. She ensured not just Austria survival,
but our place among Europe's greatest emperors.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe brand new videos, just like this a few times a week.
And as always, thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].